>> Tucker: THESE GUYS ARE WAY
MORE POWERFUL THAN ROCKEFELLER.
THANKS.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN IS A
CONSERVATIVE WHO WAS THERE
TODAY, THE HIGHEST RANKING FOR
PUBLIC AND ON THE COMMITTEE,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU TWEETED TODAY TWEET THAT WAS
HEARTENING I THINK TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE, YOU SAID "BIG TECH OUT
TO GIVE CONSERVATIVES, CLEARLY
TRUE.
IT’S TIME THEY FACE THE
CONSEQUENCES."
TO THE MANY FRUSTRATED VIEWERS
OUT THERE WHO DON’T THINK
REPUBLICANS HAVE FORCED THEM TO
FACE ANY CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS, TELL US,
SIMPLY, WITH THE SPONSOR WANTS
LENSES ARE GOING TO BE.
>> YOU GOT TO WORK ON 2:30, WE
ARE LOOKING AT THAT RIGHT NOW,
YOU MAY HAVE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT LOOKING AT CURRENT
ANTITRUST LAWS TO GO AFTER THESE
COMPANIES RIGHT NOW AND FRANKLY
WE MAY HAVE TO CHANGE THE LAW
AND WE ALSO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT YOU’VE BEEN DOING AND
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT,
CALLING THEM OUT EVERY TIME WE
SEE THE BIAS, EVERY TIME WE SEE
THEM BECOME THE FACILITATORS OF
THE MOB TO CANCEL PEOPLE, WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO CALL THEM
OUT.
TWITTER WENT AFTER ME TWO YEARS
AGO.
I’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
A COUPLE YEARS.
THEY SHADOW BAND FOUR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, ONLY FOUR GET SHADOW
BAND BY TWITTER AND OF COURSE WE
ARE TOLD "IT WAS JUST A GLITCH."
WHAT DID YOU PUT IN THE
ALGORITHM?
I THINK I SAID THAT ON YOUR
SHOW.
>> Tucker: YOU DID AND WE
AGREED BUT I’M A TALK SHOW HOST,
WE’VE GOT 4 MILLION VIEWERS OR
WHATEVER BUT MY JOB IS TO TALK.
LAWMAKERS ARE TASKED WITH
RUNNING THE COUNTRY AND PASSING
OUR LAW BY A DEFINITION AND
THESE COMPANIES OPERATE PROVIDED
THEM BY CONGRESS AND CONGRESS
HAS NEVER DONE ANYTHING TO REIN
THEM IN AND SO WE’VE GOT, WHAT,
96 DAYS UNTIL THE ELECTION,
EITHER GOING TO BE ANY
CONSEQUENCES UNTIL THEN?
>> YOU JUST MENTIONED ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING, IN 96
DAYS, 97 DAYS, WHATEVER THAT
NUMBER IS, IT’S IMPORTANT THAT
WE REELECT DONALD TRUMP AND TAKE
BACK THE HOUSE BECAUSE DO YOU
THINK JOE BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS,
AND JERRY NADLER ARE GOING TO
FIX THIS?
YOU THINK THEY’RE GOING TO STOP
BIG TECH FROM ATTACKING
CONSERVATIVES AND CENSORING
CONSERVATIVES?
I DON’T THINK SO.
REPUBLICANS AREN’T IN CONTROL.
WE ARE WORKING ON THE SENATE,
WORKING WITH THE SENATE ON THIS
230 ISSUE, LOOKING AT EVERY
REMEDY WE CAN BECAUSE HER HAS TO
BE A REMEDY FOR WHAT THEY’RE
DOING TO CONSERVATIVES.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS TO
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND MAKE
SURE DONALD TRUMP IS REELECTED.
>> Tucker: IT SEEMS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANY CANDIDATE OR
PARTY TO WIN ANYTHING IF ALL THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE RACE IS
CONTROLLED BY PEOPLE WORKING FOR
THE OTHER SIDE WHICH IS WHERE WE
ARE NOW.
LET ME ASK YOU, JIM
SENSENBRENNER HAS TAKEN MONEY
FROM GOOGLE, GOOGLE IS YOUR
SECOND-BIGGEST CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTOR IN THE LAST CYCLE,
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD GIVE
YOU MONEY?
>> LOOK, IF THEY WANT TO
EXERCISE THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
LIBERTY TO GIVE ME MONEY, I
RAISE $3 MILLION LAST QUARTER,
GOD BLESS HIM, THAT DOESN’T
CHANGE WHO I AM.
YOU SAW THAT TODAY IN THE
COMMITTEE, I WENT AFTER THEM FOR
THE THINGS YOU JUST READ,
TUCKER.
IN 2016, GOOGLE TRIED TO TAILOR
THEIR FEATURES TO HELP CLINTON
IN KEY STATES, THAT’S FROM THE
HEAD OF THEIR MULTICULTURAL
MARKETING.
>> Tucker: I’M A TALK SHOW
HOST, WE TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE
TIME.
THEY SOMEHOW HAVE A LIABILITY
EXEMPTION WHERE THEY CAN’T BE
SUED FOR GARBAGE ON THEIR SITE.
WHERE’S THE EFFORT TO DO THAT?
>> I JUST LIKE TO KNOW, ONES ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> WE ARE WORKING ON IT RIGHT
NOW WITH FOLKS IN THE SENATE,
OUR STAFF IS WORKING WITH SENATE
STAFF ON THAT ISSUE.
WHAT’S THE BEST WAY TO STRUCTURE
THAT LANGUAGE, WE ARE LOOKING AT
THAT.
ALSO AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IS DOING, BILL BARR IS LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
NOW WE MAY HAVE TO WRITE SOME
OTHER LAW.
THERE ARE THREE POSSIBLE
REMEDIES HERE.
ALL I KNOW IS THERE IS A BIG
PROBLEM AND THERE HAS TO BE A
REMEDY, WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT
IS THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION TO
TAKE BUT NONE OF IT HAPPENED,
NONE OF IT HAPPENED IF JERRY
NADLER IS STILL IN CHARGE OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS GET
ELECTED AS PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: I AM CERTAINLY NOT
ADVOCATING FOR JERRY NADLER
HAVING ANY MORE POWER THAN HE
DOES, OBVIOUSLY.
I JUST, AGAIN, I THINK MOST
PEOPLE WATCHING FEEL JUSTIFIED
FRUSTRATION THAT WE ARE RIGHT AT
THE EDGE OF THE ELECTION AND
IT’S PRETTY HARD TO WIN ANYTHING
IF THESE PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
INTERFERE IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> NO, I DO.
THE GOOD NEWS IS IN 2016 IN
SPITE OF WHAT GOOGLE DID, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAW IT FOR WHAT
IT WAS AN DONALD TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
THAT’S WHY I RAISE THAT ISSUE IN